let's bring in Daniel Jeremiah you can
follow the NFL Network analyst on
Twitter that moved the Stix NFL Network
provides live coverage of the Scouting
Combine March 1st through the 4th 9:00
a.m. Eastern and also on Saturday as
well Daniel good morning what do you
think the number one topic at the
combine is going to be well I think it's
probably gonna start with Tyler Murray
and we'll probably end with Kyle Emery
where does Antonio Brown and Robert
Kraft fit in there ooh yeah I mean I've
been locked in a cave just watching all
these college getting focused no I guess
there are a couple of the big stories up
yeah I don't know what is said about
Robert Kraft but Antonio Brown you got
to find you know is who was Pittsburgh
going to you know where's where's he
gonna go because they've said that there
are certain teams that they don't want
to send him to they don't want to send
him to the Patriots anybody else in the
AFC North with them where do you think
Antonio Brown ends up well I look at all
these different places where he could
potentially fit obviously such a great
player you could plug them in a lot of
spots and it makes sense but if you want
to get him out of the AFC selfishly I'd
like to see him go to Seattle you pair
him up with with with Doug Baldwin and
give Russell Wilson some weapons like
that let's see what Russell can do I
would love Pete Carroll will be great
for him yeah I'm wondering what you get
in return
as a former scout what would you be
looking for when you're looking at
Antonio Brown we know his talent but
yeah when what are you looking for with
him if you were thinking about bringing
him in well I mean I don't think you
find anybody in the NFL who would say
he's not a better player than Brandon
cooks even though he's older and we know
what that was able to fetch so I think
you start by asking for a 1 and some
change you know you're hoping you're
going to maybe get a 1 and that one
might not be this year's draft maybe
it's a 2021 you know maybe you end up
getting a 3 this year and they in a 1
next year that's what I would ask for
now it doesn't encourage me I don't know
if it was a smartest thing to say we've
had three teams call
even if it was CFL teams I think I would
can consider them in the mix and try and
put a little bit bigger number out there
to create a little more demand Cuyler
Murray going to the combine what do you
think that he'll do you know I I saw
some people saying well maybe he'll were
you know maybe he should refuse to do
the height and weight but that's that's
crazy there's no way I've never seen
that done it's just you can't you're
gonna have to get those measurements
I've never seen anybody pull that off so
that would be truly shocking I expect
him to do the height weight I expect him
to do all the units I'm hopeful but he's
gonna run and throw but you know see
what he wants to do there I thought
looking back on it you know we'll see
what happens here and then at the pro
day but I thought look back Jackson I
didn't understand the not running part
of it to me that's you you know it's a
big time asset it's a big part of who
you are what you do on the field we all
know he was fast but I think that would
have create a little more buzz for him
during the process so if he's healthy
and fully uh and fully ready to go even
if he wasn't gonna throw why not go out
there and run does kind of Murray's
height matter at this point you know I
don't think so I really don't to me when
you watch him but I try and say okay you
know there's the first half of the
Alabama game where I thought things kind
of closed in on him a little bit and I
questioned you know can you see I
thought he panicked a little bit and
then after that I thought he's settled
in and adjusted and I didn't think it
really became much of an issue you know
from the height standpoint to me my two
concerns with Cuyler one was the
commitment in the focus and it sounds
like that's that's in a good place right
now
what with where he is focusing on
football so we checked that box the
other one was just a bulk to be able to
show you can be durable and you know
from everything I've heard and I think
Peter King wrote about it today that
he's allegedly up to 206 pounds which is
actually two more pounds than Russell
Wilson weight at the combine so that'll
go a long way in answering that or
alleviating some of that concern if you
needed a quarterback and Haskins is on
the board from Ohio State
Kyler's Marie or other ooh yeah
you know it's I've gone back and forth
on this you could not be any more polar
opposite in terms of their skill sets I
ended up going with Marie in my my
updated nfl.com I have Marie just over
Haskins and a little bit of thinking
that's I think that I believe personally
Marie can do almost everything Haskins
can do throwing the football and now you
see Haskins works you know super
freshens a little bit more than you see
with Kyler Barry but I've seen Kyler do
it I know he can do it and then I just
think Murray can do things with his
athletic ability the casting can't do so
that's why I ended up having Murray a
little bit over hasturs yeah I'd have no
problem taking Kyler Murray I've said
that before on the program and I know
the Giants he doesn't fit in with what
they normally take you know they like
the 64 quarterback Hostetler Sims Eli
but if I have Kyler Murray's sake on
Berkeley and Odell Beckham jr. the track
team yes I've created
yeah but I've created space here I I'm
gonna make you adjust to me and the
Giants won't take Kyler Murray but I
have no issue here the other part of
this is if you're bringing in Kliff
Kingsbury and you're Arizona and you're
already bringing in something to do
something different then why not bring
in Kyler Murray if you're gonna go all
in on wide open let's have fun let's go
crazy and bring in Kliff Kingsbury and
his offensive mind then why not try to
make a deal trade Josh Rosen and take
Kyler Murray yeah I mean on you know you
look at it historically trading a
quarterback you took in the first round
after one year would be very unusual but
I don't think it would be more unusual
than hiring a head coach you just got
fires with Texas Tech's so if you've
gone out box why not go all the way
that's my point
you know if you're gonna do that and
this is what you want in Arizona then
get the guy that the guy you brought in
once and that's Kyler Murray
so the question Dan is then where you
know if we take this down the road a
little bit
um which teams make sense for Josh Rosen
if you could find a taker who is that
team the Patriots the Patriots yeah I've
got another interesting one for you what
about the Steelers Ben doesn't do well
with that I mean like Mason Rudolph I
would like to see it maybe that's just
selfishly I would just like to see it
you got to find your next guy that's
going to be I don't think it's going to
be Mason Rudolph but if the biggest
knock on the Steelers organization
currently is that you baby Ben well that
would shake it up a little bit yeah but
you just had a GM who said you know he's
our unquestioned leader in it when I got
50 he's got 52 kids underneath him I
mean it doesn't sound like they're
babying Ben it sounds like they're
empowering him yeah I mean that's that's
the other way to put it I just think
there's some people think words you want
to use preferential treatment or he's
been put on a pedestal have you but I
just think when I look at who's gonna be
that next guy you don't want to get to
the point where you know you get to the
end of Ben's career and then you start
trying to find somebody I I think you
kind of look at the situation with some
of these smooth transitions around the
league trying to have that next guy and
I want to have late yeah I could see the
Patriots doing something like this if
they're gonna be interested in a court
of like at some point they're gonna get
Tom's legitimate backup and if you could
get Rosen for value I I don't know I'd
certainly kick the tires on that yeah
and look the Arizona Cardinals have
flat-out come out and said that this is
not happening so maybe this is all just
a pipe dream but it's you know until
until the first pick is made I think
there's gonna be at least a little bit
of doubt and everybody's fine and at
least that that maybe caliber could be
the pick other hot quarterback names
well I think you've got you know you've
got marine Haskins which will take up a
lot of the conversation and then after
that to me I think there's three guys
and this is how it is too when you look
at lock and Daniel Jones is those next
two guys but then you know I think rice
family the more you watch him the more
you study him from NC State and he
doesn't
a huge arm but he's just a really really
consistent guy you know exactly you know
exactly where to go with the football
puts it where it needs to be on time and
I think he's kind of entered that
conversation with number two and that's
where we'll go from there
yeah I'm not sold on these quarterbacks
I don't know let's say it was last year
a draft or you know previous like
Haskins I think is higher than he should
be I you know I I like him I don't love
him I think in a different NFL he would
be you know he'd be a first-round pick
but you know in today's game you know
there's a few that stay in the pocket
but you know I think when you get him
out you know off his spot a little bit
then you know I'm not as thrilled with
him I just don't know if because we
don't have some great quarterbacks that
all of a sudden were elevating Haskins
Jones and Locke yeah I actually you know
I have I have Kyler Murray as the 14th
player in the draft
I have Haskins the 18th player so and I
would I would have them behind the guys
from last year Kyler Murray put it this
way I gave Kyler Murray the same grade
that I gave to Josh Allen so I had the
other I had Arnold may feel in rosin
ahead of both of these guys and then you
know wild cards Josh Allen was kind of a
wild card obviously a much bigger
package fella at least kind of that wild
card but I would add Haskins you know
behind those guys as well so I don't you
know Haskins my concern like you
mentioned when you get him off his spot
he struggles a little bit I just don't
see a lot of twitch in his lower half
you know when you watch Sam Donald as
you watch Baker Mayfield and you see the
free rusher they have that kind of lower
body twist be able to just just create a
little bit of space and I just don't
know if he's going to be able to do that
that's my concern when you kind of look
at the quarterbacks that have been
successful in the league that maybe
aren't the most mobile guys they're all
the old veterans who have so much
experience that mentally they're in a
great place where they can kind of
overcome some of their physical a lack
of twitch and athleticism and that's
going to be something that's going to
take a little bit of time for Haskins to
get there he is a very bright kid but
you don't just walk into the end
so with that knowledge base so that's my
concern safe travels there Daniel we
appreciate your time as always thank you
that's Daniel Jeremiah NFL Network
analyst former NFL scouts you can follow
him and move the sticks NFL Network
providing live coverage of the combine
March 1st through the 4th at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern also coverage on Saturday for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]